[Applause]
i think so dove didn't know he was
okay-looking
until now he doesn't believe it until 20
seconds ago he doesn't believe it but
he's jewish
100 he didn't know he was okay looking
until
dating apps and uh i remember those
things
i remember once dating apps came out and
it was just a meat market i remember him
like telling
he came to me we were having sushi we're
having he take me to this place at
sushi in l.a and of course it's like on
thursdays between like six and eight you
get like fifty percent off right yeah so
we're
like 5 59 and he's [ __ ] truffling
with the waiter like i know it's not six
but can we order now
asian action obviously probably japanese
like she's trying to oh the system
doesn't allow you to do it and he's like
yeah but just tell the chef it's like
it's a minute just wait 60 seconds right
fast talking so so we're there and uh he
starts i was like how's everything going
you don't have a girl yet or though he
said i'm getting crushed by this [ __ ]
dating app [ __ ]
i go like he talks about like the stock
market yeah
he's like we're getting murdered i'm
taking a bath on ryan
we're selling
what are you talking about what do you
mean you're getting crushed she goes
yeah it's just a [ __ ] meat market out
there right and they don't get
they don't get the the what is it what
do you call they don't get the shtick
i can't i can't do a thing what do you
mean well it's just a picture and you
know my stats aren't great you know what
i mean
how do you sure you're gay on tinder
yeah what do i do
what's the guy on tinder i mean you need
me to suck a dick
on my profile what's going on so and it
is a
fascinating thing that happened where
like dating apps kind of
[ __ ] guys with game yes they weren't
quote unquote traditionally uh handsome
like a [ __ ]
the bra or something or the brad chad
types right girls are 100
getting guys with worse personalities
now because of dating apps yes because
they're just sweating and they
they complain about it and the thing is
you know how it used to be like
you'd go to a bar and then girls said oh
it's just a girl's night tonight we're
not really talking to god
like now it's for real that they're
doing it like now it's in
because they have 50 guys that they're
each they're literally each match
on the way by the way on the way to your
engagement party andrew put this on a
sprinter bus
thank you but it was nice in the back
seat in the third row
good plane thank you it was nice send me
my car
do you you got your own car bro bro know
what i grew up here yeah
you expect to get the same car as the
[ __ ] groom and bride
are you are you going to the hotel like
they got the honeymoon
the way that i got that i got the two
queens my entitlement
shows the way that the way that he
worked like i could see his [ __ ]
brain
dude we get to the [ __ ] we get to
like the engagement party right there's
the tables right yeah they're like
the tables have like a seating thing
right now like i don't put any thought
into this see anything i'm just like i
just want some people to know like you
know sit next to each other and i want
to make sure there are any singles that
they're around right
dove starts like truffle sniffing for
the what the name placements are
and he sees he's like at the table that
me and m are up a little down
and uh i point and i go yeah you're over
there and he goes uh
and he goes okay so far
things are going according to plan
tonight like yes i'm like
like he's literally gonna be upset he
was gonna be upset if he wasn't at the
[ __ ] table hundred percent
there because the other girl didn't have
a date y'all either so you both had to
sit next to their way to set up
so that girl was in the back third row
in the little bus on the way over there
and i
one girl tells the other girl like oh
what are you doing tomorrow night i
don't know i'll go on a date let me
check hinge
literally didn't even know who she was
going to talk to just to plan that night
so what i'm saying is
back in the day guys that would go up to
girls andrew was also one of these guys
before like that was we won we did it
because we were brave
it benefited us bravery was beneficial
back in the day
and then the dating app [ __ ] it
definitely rewards cowards does it swing
back though
so now women are these generations
having these like sort of lackluster
dates we're like i'm hooking up these
hot guys but it's just like meaningless
i feel nothing
and then it swings back do you know what
i to that point you know what i heard a
girl say one of my
my girlfriend's friends said this
recently i was like uh
she said she was gonna date and i was
like how'd you meet the person and then
she said this
in like a surprise tone she was like uh
he actually like came up to me in person
yeah like like like that was novel yeah
right
and she was like yeah i thought it was
like really hot he just like walked up
to me and he's like started talking to
me and then like asked me
out and said like to go on a date to
them that's
foreign but the hutzpah if you will
still resonates man cables are turning
fast it's still [ __ ] resonating come
back
learn your perfumes i mean after after
covid
do you guys like think about like what
it's going to be like in the world like
is it going to be
i think it's going to be the roaring 20s
the great gatsby people are going to be
they're going to be going they're going
for it
think about that like someone's gonna
say have a rule or be
tense about one thing i'm gonna look
them in the face be like covet
have you ever been badly rejected by a
girl
like she just like was just like really
yeah but i live in l.a and there's some
horrible people in l.a
no no the worst thing the thing that
influences me not to my face people
don't really
offend me to my face never could admit
this blatantly
i'll take the worst rejection i'll admit
i will live
no no the worst is not to your face it's
you
your father you ever met somebody didn't
like you yeah i know some idiots
[ __ ] absolutely flaking has increased
out of
tenfold oh yeah would you guys agree
cancelled on right getting canceled
so to my face no we don't agree we're
all married yeah over here yeah
so you were getting flaked on and you've
never experienced this you couldn't
believe it
and also you were closing the deal and
you were really upset financially
because the date would cost
a certain amount of money i calculated
it it would put it all in numbers
this really is the stock market yes this
is the truffle bro
the truffle you know the stock market
bro
that's crazy so what i wonder are your
standards super high like you have a
pretty high average
yes sir so you have really it works
what's like the ugliest girl in terms of
ratings that you've ever taken down
like a four like no like like a miss
mcgregor honestly you know what i don't
go under a seven i think
because he is gay partly partly 49
the girl 49 so beautiful that like
you know how like yes oh that they look
like guys or something not that they
look like
like androgynous just like like when you
get to
i'm not getting turned on for anything
because most of me is gay so
the straight part of me needs a much
like a straight guy sees like a girl
with big titties that's super ugly and
goes yeah she's got bigger i can work
big titties
but right but if you got 49 you say 49
but they need to understand what that
means
you know what i mean do they say 45 no
yeah i know
what you're doing literally his wrist
he's salted
he's literally he is
real quick okay so i think like you can
get to a point of good looking
right like there are guys that are like
let's say these like
male models that look almost like a
feminine but you can look at them you
can make
you are an attractive human being yeah i
don't want to [ __ ] you you're some dude
but at the same time i'm not going to
lie and say you're not a beautiful
looking person
that's 49 i'll tell eat i'll tell a guy
he's gorgeous but i don't want that so
gorgeous
but i can say it because i think once
you go to 51
you're you're gay like there's no i
don't think he's 51 and 99
like you just like guys i could say like
that guy
is a good looking dude i want that guy's
eyes and abs
but i don't want to be with them
sexually my girl brought a point the
other day that she asked you where she
said why can't you be 50 50.
no because it goes over the line
[Applause]
no
you